[Music]
this is what we hoped for because this
was a dangerous mission this was people
who risk their lives to go in and help
these animals so this animals really
suffer not only lack of food and the
medicine and water and the human care
but also the military conflict have a
huge a huge impact on them and all of
them were merely traumatized from this
war
[Music]
there were approximately 300 animals
that were abandoned at the zoo and that
died in their cages
either from the the military action or
just for the no feeding I know no water
no food it was a bombing environment and
you know we were thankful that the
locals were actually feeding them some
of the army of the military were feeding
them their own food and that's what kept
them alive we have to deal on both sides
of between variables which were fighting
at this time from snipers on both sides
we have to deal with different rebel
group and if any different voice moving
immediately they will sink we are
transporting women or smuggling a human
and they will shoot us we have to deal
if there is air strike if the Russian
will pump this convoy we were aware that
the animal make big noise but the animal
forelock were very cooperative and very
quiet during the transport the winds the
first line animal arrived - to the
Turkish border we were very glad that
the Turkish ecology opens a border and
the Syrian side opens a border
incredibly how all these people come
together different Authority come
together and they were very proud to be
part of the exchange of animal from one
truck to the other even the Syrian team
were very happy to hand over the enemy
cause for him it's a mission to bring
this animal outside this war zone
by arrival of the first mile animal the
tools here or our plan in fact we have a
long trip which is at Marshall another
24 hours to transfer to the animal from
keyless or chopped and a border in
Turkey side till courage P in north of
Turkey it was very long trip very I will
see stressful trip for the animal but
because in Turkey we have the competent
team expert wild animal doctors we were
able to manage and care for the animal
during this long trip till we arrived to
Karachi Bay to the history centre in
total
[Music]
so right here last night and after we
gave the animals the first eight and a
little bit rest overnight and food and
water we start today with a vet checks
how do you sit down six minutes it'll be
ready to close the gate he can breathe
anything can happen
we were there in the rescue station in
Karachi over three weeks waiting to
premiere all the permits all the medical
examination and need the treatment for
animal to be transported
and on 10 of August we were able to move
all the animals to our men and from a
man - el mal WA the sanctuary for the
segments
[Music]
animal went to a place in Jordan it is a
parodies it's called in Mahwah which
mean it's like a place for refugee also
but refugee animal it is a species
appropriate place it's 140 hectare big
huge place considered one of the biggest
of its kind as wildlife sanctuary in
middle-east 12 hour after arrival to
Jordan and to her new home she get
harder the Lions come and this was a
great news and a miracle for us and for
the team
so the Lions get his baby in a safe
place and in a calm place and no more
noises no more bumps there is good
things happening after each night is a
morning the darks is light they do this
because it show each time when we took
alive out from this crisis zone or
conflict zone war zone and you see a
very swimming
swimming and free as its value humanity
and kindness we never give up and we
believed in humanity
[Music]